Castillo ratifica su solicitud de asilo
a México así lo informó el canciller
mexicano Marcelo ebrard desde su cuenta
de Twitter tras publicar la carta formal
de pedido el embajador Pablo Monroy me
reporta desde Lima que pudo
entrevistarse a las 13:20 horas con
Pedro Castillo en el centro
penitenciario lo encontró bien
físicamente y en compañía de su abogado
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador pidió garantías para
Castillo Entonces
nosotros pedimos que se le respeten sus
derechos humanos que se actúe
con legalidad verdadera
se protege a su familia más temprano en
Perú la corte ordenó siete días de
detención antes del juicio en su contra
por el presunto delito de rebelión se le
acusa por su intento de disolver El
Congreso cerrar la fiscalía y Llamar a
un gobierno de emergencia con toque de
queda y pedido de elecciones sin apoyo
de sus ministros el ejército las
autoridades judiciales el episodio
terminó con su arresto y la posesión de
su vicepresidenta Dina boluarte como
nueva dirigente de Perú la primera mujer
en asumir este cargo de momento boluarte
descartó elecciones anticipadas Yo sé
que hay algunas voces que indican
adelanto de elecciones Y eso
democráticamente es respetable creo que
la Asunción de la presidencia en esta
oportunidad es un poco reorientar lo que
hay que hacer con el país más adelante
en coordinación con todas las
organizaciones
estamos viendo alternativas Mientras
tanto en Lima se mantienen algunas
manifestaciones de partidarios de Pedro
Castillo que piden su Liberación y
acusan a la nueva presidenta de traición